on connaissait bien l'acteur philippe
léonard je vous propose de découvrir
maintenant l'écrivain et le poète
philippe léotard publie en effet un
recueil de textes au titre évocateur est
volontairement ambigu pas un jour sans
une ligne
c'est au délit aux éditions belles
lettres son portrait avec dominique
poncet est en écoute mal en allant son
chemin monde
pour ce dernier
et joue à bousculer les arrange
le temps d'une note encore
chikhi un maquis drogue strauss use
comme balzac
alors si le malade mais quand tout le
monde dort le matin entre se calmer
10h20 sacré mais c'est vers 8 heures à 9
heures je vais à l'école au silence et
lui donnons la tête
on peut aussi sa part de cocaïne et est
en place c'est tout simplement je ne
sais pas le sujet du livre le fusiller
ce décret à tous les jours c'est que ça
va dit avoir le nom j'ai pensé c'est
forcément un certain un certain nombre
de choses ça devenait un centre lui
histoire cette écriture mais je ne la
connais pas bien instruits
je sais pas et glg quel trip j'avais
vécu pendant cette année-là pas
confiance à parler d'eux voilà des
femmes que j'aime et cru aimer mal aimé
bien c est aux dames à chercher et à
deux chiffres est alors je suis matin
puis a promis on va se promener qui
change les gens font des coq à l'âne à
la prévert des jeux de mots à la queue
nous des jaillissements à la bo de l'ère
des fulgurances à la rimbaud et pourtant
le poète philippe iota n'en prennent que
lui-même son style et son aspiration fin